stunning testimony during yesterday's
house hearing on the origins of covet
19. former CBC director Robert Redfield
accusing Dr Anthony fauci of shutting
down debate about the coronavirus lab
leak theory listen
science has debate and they squashed any
debate we now know there was infections
all the way back into September this was
a narrative that was decided that they
were going to say this came from the wet
market and they were going to do
everything they could to support it to
negate any discussion about the
possibility that this came from a
library Louisiana Congressman Mike
Johnson is a member of the House
Judiciary Committee and the committee on
the weaponization of the federal
government and he joins us now
Congressman why was Anthony facci so
committed to pushing his narrative at
all costs and at the expense of the
truth
well because it was a much cleaner
narrative and it took the attention away
from him what Mr Redfield also testified
to yesterday is that in his words there
is no doubt that some agencies of the
federal government like the NIH and and
usaid were helping to fund gain of
function research which of course led to
the creation of this Dr fauci instead
went with the narrative that it came
from an animal because obviously that
would be an accidental natural
occurrence and the implications are far
less dangerous for him and all those
people involved so with hearing all of
this how will fauci and these entities
of the federal government how are they
going to be held accountable
well we've got to present all the facts
there's a long deliberate process that
goes along with this because we're going
to do it very deliberately this is not
about politics this is about restoring
the people's faith and our institutions
of government itself uh there will be
accountability for anyone involved in
that it appears that Dr fauci is one of
those persons to whom accountability is
owed because he effectively tried to
cover this up I mean that is what the
documents and the evidence are approving
there's mounting evidence of this he
even commissioned scientific papers to
try to advance his competing narrative
which he obviously knew was not true I
mean that's the implication here so
we're going to lay that out the American
people will be able to make those
decisions for themselves and of course
we'll make our determinations here in
Congress as well proceed accordingly the
gain of function questions by
Republicans elicited some fascinating
answers take a listen
I think there's no doubt that NIH was
funding gain or function research has
gained a function created any
life-saving vaccines or Therapeutics to
your knowledge not to my knowledge has
gain of function stopped a pandemic to
in your opinion
now in the contrary I think it probably
caused the greatest pandemic our world
has seen I mean Congressman that's bad
enough in and of itself but if we now
know gain a function is bad why are
fouchy and his acolytes still pushing it
and using Government funding to push it
not just in the United States but still
in China that makes no sense
it makes no sense it boggles the mind I
mean members of Congress have been
asking these questions for a few years
now trying to figure out why in the
world would we be engaged in this I you
know our frustration with Dr fauci is
based on the frustration of I think so
many millions of Americans people who
are asking these same questions the
answers are difficult to determine I'm
not really sure Todd and that's part of
the problem that's why we're digging in
and doing this to try to ensure that
this kind of Madness doesn't happen
again I mean this killed a million
Americans it is the greatest disruption
of our lifetimes uh effectively it went
about destroying large parts of the U.S
economy I mean the the implications of
this and the reverberations go on and on
and on and we have to ensure this never
ever happens again well speaking of
Madness the Twitter files journalists
are set to testify before the house
subcommittee on the weaponization of the
federal government today and you will be
one of those lawmakers asking them
questions what do you want to know
well listen to Twitter files detail what
we have known intuitively that has been
happening it is a fact that the agencies
of the federal government including the
FBI use the social media platforms to
censor and silence viewpoints that they
disagreed with that didn't go along with
their narrative that the political party
in charge had different ideas than many
of us that were on those social media
platforms advancing a conservative
Viewpoint or narrative that happened we
know that the FBI was effectively using
Twitter as a subsidiary and Twitter was
dutifully doing what uh the FBI
instructed them to do and that is to
censor and silence certain accounts and
and posts and tweets it went on and on
we know this and we're going to unfurl
that today for the American people to
see well it's concerning because I'm not
quite sure why the federal government
thinks they have any business sticking
their nose into that Congressman Mike
Johnson thank you so much for your time
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling and analysis